oui bonjour ici place des Festivals
salut ça va
[Musique]
c'est pour l'émission Les décrypteurs à
RDI
bonjour je peux vous poser une petite
question avez-vous déjà entendu parler
du projet de loi C11 au fédérale
avez-vous déjà entendu parler du projet
de loi C11 connaissez-vous le projet de
loi C11 monsieur le projet de loi C11
non
le projet de loi c'est 11 ça vous dit
quelque chose non je sais 21 c'est 11 et
12 c'est très bien
en fait on gagne tous à mieux connaître
le projet de loi C11 baptisé loi sur la
diffusion continue en ligne ce projet
doit l'un a pour objectif d'obliger les
grandes plateformes de diffusion
numérique comme Netflix sportify YouTube
à mettre en valeur les contenus
canadiens et à contribuer financièrement
à l'industrie culturelle canadienne
applaudi par plusieurs acteurs de
l'industrie culturelle c'est 11 étant
revanche aussi la cible de vivre
critique provenant des grandes
plateformes elles-mêmes et de plusieurs
créateurs en ligne qui évoquent
ouvertement la crainte d'être censurée
Nicolas c'est tout à fait normal de pas
être nécessairement familier avec ce
genre de projet de loi C11 faut dire
qu'il y a eu C10 avant c'était le nom
original de ce de ce projet de Douala
qui a été déposé à la Chambre des
communes donc en 2020 dans quel contexte
a été mis de l'avance Ottawa ben ça a
été mis de l'avant dans le contexte
qu'on voulait moderniser la loi de la
radio Diffusion donc essentiellement que
cette loi-là qui fait en sorte que le
CRTC peut réglementer ce qui se passe à
la télé à la radio etc s'applique
également au Web donc le CRTC réglemente
le contenu audiovisuel sur Internet
moderniser finalement exact quoi que ce
soit adapté à l'art numérique mais
finalement que les grandes plateformes
donc Netflix Spotify les Youtube de ce
monde paie d'abord des redevances envers
la culture canadienne on sait pas
exactement c'est quoi le montant c'est
le CRTC qui déterminerait ça mais il y a
aussi un aspect de promotion de contenu
canadienne donc de visibilité de contenu
canadien sur ces plateformes là
d'inclure des contenus qui sont produits
ici de leur donner une plus grande vis
une plus grande vitrine donc que ce soit
sur les pages d'accueil de YouTube
spared fine Netflix etc mais également
en termes de découvrabilité donc qui
soit plus facile à découvrir qui soit
plus recommandé qu'on en voit davantage
donc d'un côté on veut que ces
plateformes là paient leur juste peur et
d'un autre on veut que le contenu
canadien soit mis en valeur pour ce qui
est la mise en valeur du Canadien on
peut pas être contre ça c'est a priori
c'est bon ben oui c'est quelque chose
que l'industrie culturel applaudit en
général surtout au Québec c'est un quasi
consensus en faveur du projet de loi de
séance mais le code du francophone ouais
en particulier puis il faut dire qu'il y
a beaucoup d'autres lois comme ça qui
existent ailleurs dans le monde j'en ai
parlé justement avec mon ex simmor qui
faisait partie du groupe d'experts sur
la révision des lois sur les
communications qui est un peu inspiré
séance finalement ça va réinjecter de
l'argent dans le système alors c'est
approximatif mais on parle d'un milliard
et plus d'argent qui serait si honnête
je dirais une redevance financière
équivalente à celle qui s'applique
actuellement pour financer
qui allait que le CRTC va finalement
avoir le pouvoir de retirer certains
contenus de faire la censure cela donne
au gouvernement le pouvoir de forcer les
médias sociaux à changer leurs
algorithmes pour promouvoir le contenu
qu'ils veulent que vous voyez et
supprimer ce qu'ils ne veulent pas que
vous voyez il en résulterait également
une disparition des médias indépendants
pensez à tous les scandales et critiques
qui auraient pu être cachés aux citoyens
au cours des 7 dernières années c'est le
gouvernement avait eu le droit de
manipuler les algorithmes pour les
supprimer comme le scandale witcherity
le scandale de l'agacane SNC-Lavalin le
Blackface et ainsi de suite donc on
entendit parler des médias indépendants
évidemment rien à voir avec ce projet de
loi là et bien sûr le CRTC avec ce
projet de loi là n'a pas le pouvoir de
supprimer du contenu des réseaux sociaux
mais par contre c'est vrai que le CRTC
dans ses pouvoirs peut prioriser ou des
prioriser certains contenus dans des
algorithmes donc on sait pas exactement
comment ce pouvoir-là sera utilisé c'est
pas quelque chose qui est dans
l'intention je vois mais le CRTC aurait
ce pouvoir là sur le contenu audiovisuel
en ligne effectivement de prioriser au
dépriés dans des films cela étant dit
c'est là qu'on rentre dans tout l'aspect
contenu généré par des utilisateurs de
la loi C11 à l'époque où c'était C10 la
loi englobait tout le contenu
audiovisuel sur internet mais sur les
réseaux sociaux donc même une vidéo
YouTube mise en ligne par un canadien de
son chat par exemple
les fameux vidéo de chasse auraient été
encadrées par ces discussions beaucoup
mais il y a eu beaucoup de contestations
de de ça ce qui avait fait en sorte que
quand c'est 11 a été introduit à la
dernière session parlementaire ben il y
a eu une provision dans la loi une
exception qui est faite pour le contenu
généré par des utilisateurs par contre à
cette exception là il y a une autre
exception qui fait en sorte qu'un
contenu généré par un utilisateur si
génère des revenus même de manière
indirecte donc une vidéo qui générait
des revenus avec des dons par exemple
pourrait être assujetti ok ça c'est la
condition à remplir finalement ça c'est
la condition à remplir et bien sûr sur
Youtube même faire un petit revenu sur
nos vidéos donc il y a quand même une
certaine crainte de créateurs de contenu
audiovisuel en ligne que le CRTC
pourrait abuser de ses pouvoirs pour
leur vidéo c'est encore une fois c'est
pas ça l'intention de la loi mais elle
pourrait être techniquement appliquée de
cette manière-là par le CRTC et ça
inquiète certains experts dont Michael
Guess titulaire de la chair de recherche
du Canada en droit de l'Internet à
l'université ottawaerasing
et c'est juste à enfoncer plus de
content canadien c'est correct mais au
moins qu'il y a pas de censure il y a un
autre aspect aussi qui rentre en compte
que YouTube par exemple a dénoncé comme
quoi que si on force des gens à voir du
contenu qui ne les intéresse pas juste
parce que canadien ça pourrait avoir un
impact négatif sur les créateurs donc
par exemple si quelqu'un se présenter
une vidéo qui les intéresse pas il
clique dessus il écoute quelques
secondes il aime pas y mettre le pouce
vers le bas sur Youtube c'est pas ce
qu'il cherche ben ça peut affecter
négativement cette vidéo dans
l'algorithme de YouTube au grand complet
donc il y a des créateurs qui craignent
effectivement que finalement ça défait
inverse sur leur vidéo que même si son
vus par plus de Canadiens c'est pas des
gens qui sont intéressés qui vont les
voir
si tu veux pas souvent céder ta culture
puis tu penses que forçant les gens à
montrer la culture on va survivre
intitulé dans le pied désolé c'est mon
opinion pour l'instant on parle d'un
projet de loi qui est passé l'étape donc
de la Chambre des communes est aussi en
ce moment et au Sénat à savoir la
lecture donc ce sera à suivre